Mr Speaker Winchester college has a
Rowing Club a Rifle Club an extensive
art collection they charge over 45
000 pounds a year in fees why did he
hand them nearly 6 million pounds of
taxpayers money this year in what is
leveling up secretary calls egregious
State support
[Music]
Mr Speaker I'm pleased he wants to talk
about schools because we've recently
announced billions more funding
we're helping millions of the most
disadvantaged children catch up with
their lost learning
driving up school standards Mr Speaker
but during covid during covid he wanted
to keep schools closed
we shouldn't be surprised because I
listened to parents and he listens to
his Union paymasters
Mr Speaker he's leveling up secretary
I'll see him down there who after all
was education secretary for four years
said you could scarcely find a better
way of ending burning injustices than
scrapping these hands out and here's one
he talks about driving up standards just
down the road in Southampton and he'll
know this four in every 10 pupils fell
their English or math GCSE this year
four in ten is that six million pounds
of taxpayers money better spent on rifle
ranges in Winchester or driving up
stabbers in Southampton
[Applause]
[Applause]
a conservative government and thanks to
the reforms of the former education
secretary that now almost 90 percent of
schools are good are outstanding
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker whenever whenever
Mr Speaker whenever he attacks me about
where I went to school he is attacking
the hard-working aspiration of millions
of people in this country
he's attacking people like my parents Mr
Speaker this is the country that
believes in Opportunity not resentment
he
understand that and that's why he's not
fit to lead
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if he thinks the route to better
education in this country is tax breaks
for private schools in the hope they
might hand that sum that down to state
school that's laughable trickle-down
education is nonsense and Mr Speaker
it's not just the leveling up secretary
his education Minister sitting there
asks how much better would it be if
conservatives got rid of these handouts
he talks about his record it's simple he
can carry on being pushed around by the
lobbyists giving away 1.7 billion pounds
to private schools every year or we can
put that money to good use in the Tory
Scandal he talks about his record
hundreds of thousands of children
leaving school without the
qualifications that they need I've made
my choice what's his
prime minister Mr Speaker we're
improving School standards for every
pupil in this country
[Music]
for writing more good and outstanding
schools more investment in every single
school but he talks about choice this is
about supporting aspiration Mr Speaker
and that's what this government is proud
to do
Mr Speaker he really does need to get
out more and he taught he talks about
aspirations Mr Speaker they are killing
off aspiration in this country and it's
not just education why is the dream of
home ownership far more remote now than
it was when his party came into Power 12
years ago
prime minister well Mr Speaker what have
we done in those 12 years the highest
the highest number of new homes started
in 15 years
budget largest number of first-time
buyers in 20 years
he taught he talked about 10 years ago
what do we inherit the lowest level of
house building in a century
Mr Speaker would you believe it
Mr Speaker the simple fact is this every
year the age at which people can buy
their first home goes up at this rate
under this government a child born in
the UK today wouldn't be able to buy
their first home until they're 45. now I
love my kids but I don't want to cook
them dinner in 30 years time now Mr
Speaker
I I I've heard
I've heard
I've heard you I've heard he's having a
relaunch apparently it's called
operation get tough
so so how tough is he gonna get with his
back benches who are blocking the new
homes this country so badly needs
Mr Speaker we're delivering record
numbers of new homes under this
government that's what we're doing he he
talks he talks about toughness Mr
Speaker he's too weak to stop dozens of
his own MPS joining the picket lines
if he wants to support if he wants to
support those hard-working families and
show some leadership why doesn't he
confirm right now that no labor MPS are
going to join those picket lines
Mr Speaker whichever way you slice it
it's always the same whether it's
private schools oil Giants or those who
don't pay their taxes here every week he
hands out cash to those that don't need
it every week he gets pushed around and
every week he gets weaker
but I can help him with this one he
doesn't need to do another grubby deal
if he wants to defeat that Amendment
from his anti-growth back benches on
National targets for housing labor will
lend him the votes to do so country
before party that's the labor way why
doesn't he try it
[Applause]
too weak to confirm no one on the picket
line but Mr Speaker it's the same old
labor ideas more debt more inflation
more strikes and more migration he's too
he tells this party what they want to
hear I'll take the difficult decisions
for this country and that's the choice
Mr Speaker it's the politics of
yesterday with him or the future of the
country with me